في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها تجري تدريبات تكتيكيه بطائرات مقاتله
فوق بحر البلطيق هدفها الرئيسي هو اختبار
الجاهزيه لاداء العمليات القتاليه وعمليات
المهام الخاصه وقالت وزاره انه بالاضافه
الى تحسين المهارات تقوم طواقم الطائرات
المقاتله بمهام قتاليه على مدار الساعه
لحراسه المجال الجوي لك
في غضون ذلك افادت الاستخبارات البريطانيه
بان القوات الاوكرانيه سيطرت على قريه
كرانسكا في وتستعيد لاول مره اراضي سيطرت
عليها روسيا منذ عام 2014 واضافت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان الهجمات
الاوكرانيه المتعدده المتزامنه مؤخرا في
جميع انحاء الدومباس قد ارهقت قوه القوات
الشيشانيه المقاتله في هذه المنطقه
ومعنا من دنيات كارمن جو خضار كارمن كيف
تصفين لنا الوضع من هناك في ظل حديث عن
هجمات على بلدات في خرسون وهجوم متواصل
ايضا في القرن
نعم عثمان في مخص القرم الهجمات تتكرر
والاستهدافات بالاحرى تتكرر على هذه
المنطقه هذه الهجمات تستهدف غالبا سكك
الحديد في تلك المنطقه صبيحه هذا اليوم
رئيس القرم اعلى عن اعلن عن استهداف لاحدى
سكك الحديد ولكنه قال ان اصلاح هذه السكه
سيتم غالبا اليوم استهدفت اخرى تجري
احيانا بالمصيرات لا يكون لها فاعليه
كبيره ولكن لها رمزيه مرتبطه بان اوكرانيا
تشدد على انها تريد استعاده شبه جزيره
القرم الذي كانت روسيا التي كانت روسيا قد
ضمتها عام 2014 فيما خص الجبهات عثمان
يمكن القول ان الهجمات تكثفت في الايام
الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم المواقع العسكريه
الروسيه تتحدث عن معارك ضاريه بالتحديد
عند هذا التقاطع بين دانيتسكو
وزابولوجيا وبالتحديد ايضا
الحديث يجري عن معارك ضاريه بين القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه في تلك
المنطقه هناك مسعا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه للتقدم ولكن كل هذه الهجمات
يتم صدها وفق اعلانات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ووفقاء المعطيات التي تنشرها
المواقع العسكريه الروسيه اليوم هناك مسعى
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه للتقدم ايضا في
منطقه ريف نوبل بالامس تحدثت الجهه
الاوكرانيه عن السيطره عن هذه على هذه
المنطقه ولكن التاكيدات الروسيه ان هذا
الامر لم يتم لغايه الان والمعارك مستمر
اذا ما تحدثنا عن خرسون عثمان هذه
المقاطعه التي كنا قد قلنا ان المعارك
تاجلت فيها بفعل تفجير سدك خفقه وجراء
الحديث حتى قبل تفجير السد ونشرت مقاطع
مصوره انذاك لمحاولات اوكرانيه لعبور نهر
دينيبرو باتجاه المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه اخر المعطيات الوارده من
تلك المنطقه ان القوات الاوكرانيه استطاعت
بعدد قليل جدا من الجنود العبور الى منطقه
سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه يقول موقع ريبار
العسكري ان هذه القوات الاوكرانيه تحتمي
تحت جسر انطونوس في هذا الجسر الذي كان قد
استهدف في العام الماضي وايضا في خرسون
خدمات الطوارئ في المقاطعه المواليه
لروسيا تحدثت عن استهدافات وقصف باكثر من
30 قذيفه باتجاه هذه المقاطعه باتجاه خمس
بلدات كانت قد طالتها الفيضانات الناتجه
عن ستكخوفكا اليوم بعد ما جرى وبعد هذا
التمرد المسلح الذي قادته قوات فاجنر
وخروج قوات فاجنر من المعادله اليوم
الانظار شخصه الى الميدان وما سيخلفه هذا
الفرح نظرا لان الرئيس الروسي عثمان تحدث
يوم امس عن ان هناك فرصه لهؤلاء المقاتلين
اذا ما ارادوا الانضمام الى القوات
المسلحه الروسيه